okay do you ever go on Twitch and watch
people play games yeah yeah all the time
I love video games I like music video
games and fashion and movies but I love
video games okay so what's your like all
time top five video game
ever video games ever ever it could be
any console come on Devil May Cry God
damn Grand Theft Auto Max Payne three
okay
um dark game Uncharted all of them fire
PlayStation guy yeah and uh hmm I don't
know what I see in this
um
[Music]
so far you got a lot of gas man I'm
gonna say Resident Evil I like Resident
Evils
which which was your favorite Resident
Evil I like two ready three and four two
and three were crazy facts when I was a
little kid I had the first one that was
like my second or third PlayStation game
bro that [ __ ] scared the [ __ ] out of me
is playing that [ __ ] now is just like
them games you got I don't know you play
that [ __ ] alone at night that [ __ ]
happens [ __ ] up it's scary but it's a
good vibe Metal Gear Solid it's my [ __ ]
better get silent love that too ain't
gonna lie play every video game ever all
of them even like nerd games anime games
whatever I really do a little video game
so you're just a big gamer yo do you
have a twitch Channel
I had way before I started wrapping
that's what I would go do without like
that because he's getting a bag over
there yeah yeah him and T painter just
[ __ ]
making they're like printing money
playing video games this is hard bro
have you done the thing where you like
uh you pretend what's it called role
playing on GTA nah I haven't done it I
don't have it um you gotta like do that
over the computer like a desktop right
yeah that seems like too much work I've
never played games on a on a computer I
want to but I don't got the time right
now it's a lot of commitment I just need
the controller
they're pretty serious like if you break
character they shoot you yeah and then
they kick you out yep that's that's like
why would I do that when I have to live
a life in real life yeah yeah that's
fair